all these people you're sitting here
including my family my road family
everybody that works me on the business
side over the works TV show everybody
works in my new label that I love and
supports Artistry which is so nice and
fresh
um it it's a really cool thing to be
surrounded by people that aren't yes
people they tell you the truth they tell
you
um honestly their opinion and I I love
that from the beginning with Idol all
three of you are very honest with me and
and yeah what's up that's my kiddos
they're getting hungry
um they're like great you got a star
let's go to Mickey D's um uh no so but I
just wanna I just wanted to say thank
you because it's to be surrounded even
like my my band on the road my family
like last night we're listening to my
new album and they're telling me what
they love they don't it's just I have
people like that and I think that's
important to have not just yes people
around you but people that actually love
you and and care about you and and give
their honest advice and I've always
welcome that and I think that is why I'm
here today
um not just because of myself but
because of having just constantly teams
of people that that love you and support
you and really want to make your dreams
come true while making their dreams come
true you know so
um I don't know it's just a weird thing
to be here like they were saying earlier
Lupita was saying this is where I won 20
years ago and and I'm with Paula I would
be lying if I was like I knew it I
didn't so
um I I feel very lucky and fortunate
because I know a lot of talented people
that love singing in an amazing ad and
writing songs and even talk show hosts I
think a lot of people could do that and
I just feel very fortunate that
um I get the chance and you know there
are dreams you didn't know you had and
they and they end up happening and you
feel super blessed and I love having my
kiddos here and my family my son is
slowly taking his Trident apart that's
that's a sign that we should wrap it up
um that's their way of playing the music
um but anyway but it's just a really
special thing and I feel very honored
and I I don't feel deserving um because
I I don't think people realize how many
people actually make all of this happen
and um Jason being one of those people
that was up here before like I would
have no career like I've had without him
um he just knows me as a human and also
as an artist we complement each other so
well
um you know we're very different in that
sense we complement each other and all
my shows touring like I would literally
not be able even the talk show you know
we're doing it together as a team and
and um and it it it's just it's amazing
for somebody to have that kind of
partnership
um you know and especially well that's I
think my longest relationship
congratulations
we don't all make it
um but um anyway but thank you so much
Jason thank you Rhonda his wife because
I've been stealing him for 20 years on
the road and they have both raised two
amazing kids and they are just the
parents you look up to and they're such
great individuals and and having to all
the my bands here like having to loan
your loved one on the road for so long I
can't imagine so thank you so much for
that sacrifice for us as a team and
thank you to my band as well and my Glam
Squad
because
this would be very different if I didn't
have them it'd look real different
um but thank you so much I really
appreciate it and please children just
smile one time for mommy by the star
okay just one thank you so much guys
thank you fans y'all are so incredible
thank you for the support